Nintendo started off the week with a
bang by announcing an absolutely massive
sale for switch games including
top-notch titles with some even marked
as high as 50 off heck some or even 80
off not sure if that's a mistake you
guys think that's a mistake these
actually even include some first party
titles which you guys know Nintendo
rarely ever discounts their first party
games they're calling this their hyper
Max sale and it runs through June 25th
2023. I'm gonna give you my personal top
10 picks from the list and we'll start
with Persona 4 Golden I played this gym
back in 2012 when it was released on the
Playstation Vita and I was absolutely
blown away it was my first time ever
playing a Persona game in Persona 4
Golden you'll explore other worldly
dungeons take down monstrous shadows and
confront the darker sides of oneself as
you inch closer to the truth behind the
serial murder cases new quality of life
features include improved graphics and
smoothness difficulty selection and a
quick save functionality you can also
choose between Japanese and English vo
it's currently marked as 20 person off
which brings the price down to 15.99 and
that is an absolute steal for such a
top-notch game that still holds up even
in 2023. at number 9 we have the Elder
Scrolls 5 Skyrim anniversary edition
which is marked as 50 off bringing the
price down to 34.99 look I'll be honest
with you guys Skyrim it's among my
favorite games ever made I platinumed it
back when it came out on PS3 but even
I'm tempted to buy it again to have a
portable version that I could play
anytime winner of more than 200 Game of
the Year Awards the Elder Scrolls 5
Skyrim celebrates 10 years of
adventuring in stunning detail the
anniversary edition includes a decade
worth of content the critically
acclaimed core game and add-ons of
Skyrim special edition plus pre-existing
and new content from creation Club
including quests dungeons bosses weapons
spells and more moving on to number
eight we have death's door an
action-adventure title from devolver
digital reaping Souls of the dead and
punching a clock might get monotonous
but it's honest work for a crow the job
gets Lively when your assigned soul is
stolen and you must track down a
desperate Thief to a realm Untouched by
death or creatures grow far past their
expiry and overflow with greed and power
track down and defeat colossal tyrants
with stories and motivations of their
own experience a somber yet Darkly
comedic Tale uncovering the Truths
Behind the flow of souls the role of the
crows and the origin of the doors you
can own it today on switch for only 9.99
which is 50 off its regular price coming
in at number seven on our list we have
chicory a colorful tale which I've
recommended before here on this channel
it's just an absolutely gorgeous title
that can be enjoyed by Gamers of all
ages chicory a colorful tale is a
top-down Adventure game in a coloring
book world where you can draw on
anything use your painting powers to
explore new places solve puzzles help
your friends and change the world like
death's door it's currently available
for 9.99 again 50 off its normal price
and just outside the top five coming in
at number six we have ninokuni Wrath of
the White Witch which is available for
80 off that's right 80 which means you
can own today for only 9.99 This
Charming tale unfolds to the use of
animation storyboarded and created by
the legendary Studio Ghibli ninokuni
combines beautiful animated visuals
masterful storytelling and a sweeping
score to create an epic role-playing
Adventure like no other at number five
we have yet another one of my favorite
games ever made in its Dark Souls
remastered look I know the souls games
aren't for everyone and it took me a few
tries before they really clicked with me
but now I just absolutely can't get
enough of these games it's honestly
difficult for me to rank them but
there's something very special about
Dark Souls 1 particularly its level
design and World design in this version
you can re-experience the critically
acclaimed genre defining game that
started it all beautifully remastered
returned to lordran in stunning detail
Dark Souls remastered includes the main
game plus the Artorias of the Abyss DLC
this marks the franchise's debut on a
Nintendo platform and for the first time
ever can be played on the go with
Nintendo switch it's currently marked 50
off which means you can snag it today
for just 19.99 Lego Star Wars the sky
Walker Saga deluxe edition takes the
number four spot on our list this one is
actually 60 off right now bringing the
price down to 27.99 the deluxe edition
includes seven downloadable content
character packs and the digital Edition
also includes an exclusive classic
Obi-Wan Kenobi playable character
players will relive the Epic story of
all nine films in the Skywalker Saga and
it all starts with picking the trilogy
of their choice to begin the journey you
can also play as iconic heroes and
villains with more than 300 playable
characters from throughout the Galaxy my
oldest got this one for his birthday
recently and I can personally say both
of my kids have really been having a
blast with it we've now reached the
number three spot and I have to give
this one to another Persona game Persona
5 Royal prepare for the award-winning
RPG experience in this definitive
edition of Persona 5 Royal featuring a
treasure Trove of downloadable content
included explore Tokyo unlock personas
customize your own personal thieves den
and experience alternate endings become
the ultimate Phantom thief and defy
conventions discover The Power Within
and fight for justice in the definitive
edition of Persona 5 Royal this version
includes over 40 items of previously
released downloadable content and you
can also choose between Japanese and
English vo it's currently available for
35.99 which is 40 off the regular price
all right at number two this one
actually blew my mind the Star Wars
Heritage pack can be had for 50 off its
regular price which means for 39.99 you
can own seven iconic Star Wars games
including both Knights of the Old
Republic games I actually had no idea
these were even available on the
Nintendo switch unless I'm missing
something I don't even think they're
available to buy on a PS5 right now I
have such fond memories of playing
Knights of the Old Republic if you
haven't played it I'm not gonna spoil it
here but one of the best stories not in
just a Star Wars game but in any video
game ever amazing twist at the end I'll
leave it to that now before we get to
number one here are some honorable
mentions that just missed the cut
seriously guys this is one of the best
switch sales that I've ever seen we have
the GTA Trilogy for thirty dollars
Diablo 3 resurrected for 13 Rogue Legacy
for three dollars Crash Bandicoot insane
Trilogy for sixteen dollars it takes two
for thirty dollars overcooked all you
can eat for twenty dollars and so much
more seriously guys you gotta check this
out and that brings us to number one and
for me it's Gotta Be Metroid dread which
is marked down to 41.99 or 30 off its
regular price again for a Nintendo first
party title especially a title that's
not that old I mean this is incredible
Nintendo very rarely does this parkour
over obstacles lie through tight spaces
counter enemies and battle your way
through the planet through her countless
Mission Samus has never experienced a
threat like the dread of zdr gain
abilities in return to previous areas to
find new areas and hidden upgrades in
classic Metroid gameplay Planet zdr
sprawling map is home to many secrets to
discover and Powers Define you'll need
to be prepared to evade and Destroy Emmy
robots and overcome the dread plaguing
CDR alright guys after buying all these
games man I really hope that the next
gen Nintendo switch is Backward
Compatible it's got to be coming soon
right I actually made a video recently
where I asked AI to help me market and
create a new Nintendo switch and
backwards compatibility is one of the
features that sounds like a video you
might be interested in check it out on
the right side of your screen now as
always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon